it's often said football and politics  should never mix but in Brazil and  Serbia they often do  [Music]  Serbia's President Alexander vucic  claims he took part in the maximir  stadium Riot of 1990. violence erupted  between factions of the Dynamo Zagreb  and Red Star Belgrade funds in what is  now viewed as an early Omen of the  brutal Croatian war of independence  today vouchech's government is accused  of being lacks on punishing  nationalistic football Hooligans and  before the Brazilian team came to Qatar  there was a campaign for this shirt to  be replaced with this one after support  as a populist outgoing president jair  bolsonaro attempted to appropriate the  famous yellow Jersey as their uniform he  may have lost the election in a deeply  divided Brazil but for thousands of his  supporters the National Football kit  embodies his belligerent brand of  nationalism  [Music]